SPEAKER: Today in
America, there really
is only one unforgivable
sin and that
is to deviate from
the accepted script
when speaking of
protected identity groups.
It is to say something,
whether intentionally or not,
that either offends
protected identity groups
or that the elites find
offensive on their behalf.
What I think is important
to grasp from the outset
is that identity
politics today is not
just the dominant ideology
when it comes to civil rights,
it's the dominant ideology
in America period.
If you look at prominent
politicians, professors,
producers, pundits, fortune 500
CEOs, tech gurus, journalists,
all of the famous credentialed
and successful people
who comprise our ruling
class, they either
all affirm the tenets
of identity politics,
or at the very least
are deferential to them.
Americans are now divided into
favored and disfavored groups,
and civil rights
law, we are told,
should not apply to
the favored groups.
Identity politics is demanding
that we judge people,
not by the content
of their character,
but by the color of
their skin, their sex,
and their sexual orientation.
And it demands that we
do so in perpetuity.
It rejects the principle
of what James Madison once
called equal rights
under equal laws,
and it instead demands that
we build a modern caste
system that privileges some
groups over others in our laws
and culture.
Identity politics is not
answering the question,
who am I, although it does have
an answer to that question.
Its primary focus, rather,
is the much deeper question
of why is there
evil in the world,
and identity politics provides
a clear and unambiguous answer
because of straight white men.
Identity politics takes and
modifies the Christian teaching
on sin and now no longer
applies to everyone but only
to the oppressor groups.
But here's the more
important modification.
It offers no hope of salvation
or redemption from sin.
Equal group outcomes are now the
measure of equal opportunities
between groups.
And under this logic,
all disparities
can only have one
explanation, discrimination.
All disparities are
blamed on discrimination,
and anyone who suggests
otherwise is immediately
called a sexist and
a racist in order
to silence dissent
and stymie inquiry.
And here of course ultimately
is the great paradox
of this focus on group results.
It requires
discrimination, in order,
it says, to eliminate
discrimination.
If you focus on results,
this will inevitably
lead you to deny positions
to some people on the basis
of their skin color, their race,
their ethnicity, their sex,
their sexual
orientation, you name it.
The main reason that
identity politics
exerts such a powerful
pull in America
is because it suggests that
we can either embrace identity
politics or remain callously
indifferent to the well-being
of fellow Americans who
happen not to look like us.
This, in truth,
is a false choice.
Identity politics
should be rejected,
not because it demands
justice for those
who have been unjustly treated,
but because it poses a threat
to Republican self-government
by corroding patriotic ties
and demanding special
treatment rather
than equality under the law.
[MUSIC PLAYING]